hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and I'm here to tell you that we're
finally done filming iron lung
this has been a very long journey and
it's a journey that has taken way more
time than I ever thought it could but we
are finally done and that means that I
can finally get back to making videos
I've been missing it a lot I've been
missing it a lot more than I ever
thought I would
um just the regular routine of making
videos getting interrupted by going out
and filming something even bigger
technically still making a video just
one very big intense video but I'm
finally done and it's great to be able
to commit yourself to something so fully
and I can't wait to tell you more about
it and I know you have so many questions
about it and I'm unfortunately not going
to be able to answer a lot of them but I
can tell you I am incredibly proud of
what we are making here I still have to
edit it there's still post-production
there's still time in between now and
when it finally gets released
but this was a new one this was another
level this was just crazy if you've been
watching my channel long enough you know
that I often go off and I make these
crazy projects and then I release them
and then you can see them and all the
hard work that goes into them is insane
and for some reason I convinced myself
that this one wouldn't be nearly as much
effort as say in space with markiplier
or heist with markiplier or any of the
other things that I've done
but honestly it was so much more in a
good way and in a bad way but mostly in
a good way in a bad way because I wasn't
able to tell you guys anything I wasn't
able to keep up with content I wasn't
able to paint the picture of the story
of what is going on behind the scenes
but I'll tell you that I am incredibly
proud of the stuff that we're making
I'm incredibly proud to be able to bring
this game to life in a movie like such
an incredibly rewarding experience but
my God has had taken a lot of my time
there were so many crazy things that
went into these past few months that I
can't even put it into words not that I
could tell you right now because a lot
of it would be a big fat spoiler but in
addition to just filming the movie so
many other things landed in these two
months I talked about that in the other
update videos but it's just insane that
it all happened now like the Spotify
thing distractible go the brand deal
with this like Creator clash and on top
of that the various other things and the
movie
like I've wanted to record videos so
badly but I I literally woke up went to
go film got back home planned for the
next day and then went to bed that is my
entire life that was my entire life for
the duration of filming this movie and
now
it's done
like I can't even believe it's done I
can't wait to get back home and I can't
wait to get back in recording videos
again I can't wait for the uh just this
simple routine of making videos on
YouTube and making videos for you guys
because I'm making this for you guys
obviously I mean you know that this
movie is just another project that I
want to push myself on and learn new
things and I have learned so many new
things
and I've opened up my eyes to so many
new possibilities of other things that I
can make the the educational experience
and the kind of inspirational
experiences Ben is is I don't know I
just
it's awesome to be able to work with
such a good crew it's awesome to be able
to translate this game into another
version so that you guys can enjoy it
it's it's great to be able to push
myself it was great to be able to
release that teaser trailer and if you
don't know what I'm talking about I
released a teaser trailer for iron lung
last week and you guys I mean you guys
went nuts you guys guys
but in a good way I know that you guys
are usually going ape for one thing
or another but
it was really really cool to see the
response to this one it was like and and
Beyond just you guys Beyond just normal
uh YouTube hype there were articles
written about this the teaser trailer
the fact that I was making this movie
the fact that this was getting put into
a movie in the first place like there
were actual articles from news
organizations and like 30 different
Publications made a story about it and
it got to the top of the movie subreddit
like it was talked about and people were
making wild conjectures about what the
movie could possibly be and I can tell
you that even even in my wildest
imaginations of what it would be as I
was writing it
it is
it is so much more I can't wait for all
this I've never been more excited about
making things I've never been more
excited about getting back and doing
videos again I've never been more
excited about making these kinds of
bigger projects it was hard it was
extremely hard
but it was also extremely rewarding
which is my favorite it's my favorite
Crossroads of those two things something
that is very difficult and challenging
but is incredibly fulfilling and
rewarding
and that's all I've ever wanted out of
making stuff on the internet that's all
I've ever wanted about making stuff in
general it's all I've ever wanted out of
my life is to have something that was
tough
but rewarding and
like I just really truly appreciate the
opportunity to do it and I know that you
guys are eager and you want to know more
about it and you want me to answer all
your questions and you have so many
questions
but just
be patient
wait a second the answers will be there
soon and you'll get all you need to know
very very soon but for now I need to get
back home and I need to work on the edit
because I am editing it there's a lot of
post-production to do David the
developer of the game he has been
involved every step of the way Andrew
holshold who is an incredible composer
is going to make the soundtrack and he
made the the piece of music that was in
the teaser trailer just this incredible
haunting piece then just I wanted to
make sure that that teaser trailer was
something special that would not only
showcase yes we're turning the game into
the movie but also to Showcase it's
going to sound incredible
because this movie is based in sound
obviously there's visuals components to
it
um the story and everything but rest
assured it is going to sound
unbelievable the amount of people that
have dedicated their time and their
efforts and their skills into this
project is like more than I ever could
have hoped for and it's all to make a
better movie for you guys to enjoy
you guys will be able to see later this
year I'm gonna edit it as soon as I get
home I'm gonna get started on the edit
then post-production you know visual
effects sound music all of it's going to
come together
and then you guys are gonna see it
on a big screen
that's kind of crazy I wanna
I wanna set a standard you know I want
to set a standard for myself
I only ever want to set new standards
for myself to send goals to uh Chase to
explore new ideas new things I've never
tried before I've learned so much about
myself and doing these things and I
still have so much left to learn
and that's both scary and exciting but I
know I said I was going to keep it short
and I'm still talking but just thank you
guys
thank you so much for your patience
thanks for you for being there when I'm
making these crazy things and thank you
for
just
watching
thank you for watching and as always
I will see you
in the next movie
bye-bye